let's talk about that georgia voting law
here's what's in the law that was signed
by governor kemp
yesterday for mailing absentee voting
you will now need an id
number which could be a driver's license
or state id
that replaces signature checking the law
limits the use of ballot drop boxes
including the number of drop boxes in
each county
it's now a misdemeanor to hand out food
and beverages in voting lines and some
of those lines can be long we remind you
despite some of these restrictions it
actually expands in person
early in person voting for primary and
general elections
uh so let's go now to cbs news election
law expert david beckner for more on
this
uh david you've been following these
election laws what's your take on this
one
uh good morning tony it's um it's
important to note first that all of
these efforts
in the states like georgia are based on
the big lie based on the lie that the
election lacked integrity when in fact
this was the most secure and transparent
election
we've ever had and the rush to pass
these laws
does raise concerns president biden was
absolutely right yesterday when he
called the effort
anti-american but this particular law as
it ended up
was kind of a mixed bag as you pointed
out there are some things in there that
are bad and there are some things in
there that are not so bad so for
instance
there are limits on the ability of third
parties to
give people who are waiting in line food
and water there are
limits on uh dropbox locations and
dropbox availability to drop a mail
ballot off
uh the um driver's license number
requirement on
a mail ballot is actually probably it
could be a net good it's similar very
similar to what they do in minnesota and
it
means they don't have to check
signatures anymore which could mean
that fewer ballots get rejected
particularly because georgia has
a very good automated automatic voter
registration system
and it also um yeah go ahead well i was
going to say uh david
in the weeks leading up to the passage
and signing by governor kemp there were
major concerns about some more
restrictive aspects of the law
that did not make it in what are those
yeah there were
at least three big things that didn't
make it into the law that i think it's
great that they weren't in the law one
was a rollback of that automatic voter
registration system which leads georgia
to have some of the most accurate voter
lists in the country
there is also a significant rollback
proposed about mail voting that is not
in the law there's still
ample opportunity for mail ballot
options in georgia
and finally there were some really
really difficult to understand
limitations
around early voting specifically around
weekend day sunday days when
african-american churches push voters
out to go souls to the polls
that is not in the bill currently
actually even early voting is expanded
in the current bill with two
saturdays and counties have the option
to provide for sundays as well
and david as a matter of fact this is a
solution in search of a problem there is
not widespread fraud in this country or
in the state of georgia and yet we have
43 states pursuing similar restrictions
on voting
what does this this passage in georgia
need for those other efforts
well i think we're going to be keeping
an eye on some laws in other states
particularly states like arizona and
texas and even florida
where um mostly republicans actually are
passing laws trying to restrict voting
trying to roll back things that have
been in place for decades that voters
like
and that actually lead to integrity
their early voting
mail voting it helps election integrity
it gives you an early warning system if
there's a problem
and so states should be really looking
for ways to expand the franchise and let
people vote
conveniently over a great number of days
and it's unfortunate to see states
trying to roll back those measures in
this kind of rushed environment
based on an entire lie yeah i think
turnout would be something that all
americans could root for david becker
thank you very much